nous avons vu le flash blanc bleuté à l'extérieur de
la fenêtre et j'ai eu la sensation de
voler dans les airs
évidemment le bâtiment tombait comme
le reste des bâtiments de la ville
et mon corps tombait avec lui
[Musique]
quand ID a pris conscience  dans l'
obscurité totale et les devoirs,
je me suis retrouvé coincé sous les décombres, je
ne pouvais pas bouger mon corps, je savais que j'étais
face à la mort et j'ai commencé à entendre mes
camarades de classe demander l'aide de leurs
mères et des gens de Dieu, puis tout à coup,
quelqu'un par derrière a jeté ma gauche
épaule et dit n'abandonne pas
n'abandonne pas continue d'avancer continue de trembler continue de
donner des coups de pied j'essaie de te libérer tu vois
le rayon de soleil passer à travers ce corbeau qui s'ouvre
vers lui c'est ce que j'ai fait
[Musique]
ils n'ont aucune chance ils ont simplement  pari
vaporiser incinéré carbonisé sans
laisser de trace je ne sais toujours pas où ma soeur a
disparu sans os mal connu que
mes camarades de classe pas des gens 7000
disparaissent à la chaleur de 4000 degrés
Celsius mais vous savez ce que je lo  ok retour
la situation catastrophique n'a été causée
que par la bombe un poème et aujourd'hui
nous en avons environ quatorze mille
chacun d'eux mille fois plus
destructeur que les vieilles bombes régionales pour bébés
[Musique]
aux dirigeants des pays à travers
le monde
I  je vous en supplie si vous aimez cette planète
vous signerez ce traité l'arme nucléaire
a toujours été immorale maintenant elles sont
aussi illégales ensemble allons de l'avant
et changeons le monde
[musique
] c'est la réalité que nous avons apprise d'
hiroshima et de
nagasaki  citoyen
apprenons cela